télé crochet rêve ou des illusions on
nabil al hassani qu'est notre invité
merci bilal venir se voit pas comment je
vais participer à des télé crochets et
c'est absolument pas grâce à ça que vous
en êtes aujourd'hui vous en êtes vous
avez participé à la saison 2 de
l'émission se paye ce qu'ils voyaient
daffé the breaking wave vous
interprétiez le titre wise like phoenix
de conchita veulent regarder on a des
images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
changer le goût j'aime d'où tu préfères
à moi je préfère comme ça je vais la
découvrir
c'est un garçon aimable merci sympa mais
je veux dire vidal hassani par contre
vous je viens de découvrir que vous à
tous merci alors et c'est vrai que je
voyais ce kit ça s'est très bien passé
ouais c'était cool c'était cool si tu
perds est très très très sympa c'était
est en fête et après vous avez fait vous
avez participé à l'émission x factor en
angleterre
ouais pour finalement refusé d'aller
plus loin alors que vous aviez ou quatre
revers de votre souris promenez pas été
plus loin
yes alors y as alors c'était très très
cool mais en fait c'était un rêve
d'enfant de faire de faire x factor
parce que c'est pour moi la question
donc vous sachiez x factor c'est
l'émission phare en angleterre way a
créé des missions ouais ya eu en direct
shalit elle mixe états unis phil darwin
donc pour moi c'était vraiment un gros
truc donc j'ai voulu essayer le truc je
trouvais que l'ambiance était un peu
chelou genre
c'était très très très très télé et
c'est cool mais sur en fait c'était très
différente voice quitter je devais m'y
attendre parce que son nouveau disque et
c'est beaucoup plus bienveillants parce
qu'on est des enfants donc aussi un
tueur c'est pas la même chose
et là c'était c'était un peu trop pour
moi c'est un peu tout est peut-être le
coup était anglais aussi est alors
justement parce qu'il ya même certains
grands gagnants de télé crochet qui ont
complètement disparu des écrans vous
avez un petit récapitulatif
si je vous disais m'aguerrir regarder on
l'a pas
ma
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le la
mode dans le courant de la nuit m
pour quelques-uns qui cartonne comme
amel comme jennifer il y en a beaucoup
qui galèrent la dent dans ce cas-là voir
que magalie vaé tf1 était étaient en
tout mais parce que elle était qualifiée
à chaque fois ils n'en voulaient plus
depuis le début c'est vrai alors n'en
voulait pas je vous le dis à chaque fois
à chaque fois sur place il était fou
après que les patrons de la chaîne était
fou possible allociné des disques c'est
vrai m d'abord une bien sûr sur un bel
abbès je pense que dire télé-crochet
rêve ou désillusion c'est ça va plus
loin que ça c'est c'est ce métier c'est
pas elle exhale pas seulement les télé
crochets c'est la dure réalité de ce
métier qui peut être violent et et où
tout peut basculer du jour au lendemain
et ça c'est le à partir du moment où je
veux juste être la personne qui dit que
quand tu choisi ce métier
à un moment donné faut arrêter de te
plaindre mais il ya des moments et même
quand tu es passé professionnel et que
tu es connu et reconnu ben tu peux un
moment donné tu retrouves au fond du
trou bien sûr après c'est à toi tu as
décidé de vivre de ta passion c'est une
vie de troubadour et s'est pas fait que
pour passer tout le temps à la télé
gagner plein d'argent ces thèmes chantés
magalie vaé on la voit pas l'attendre
mais qui vous dit qu'elle est en train
qui fait sa vie est chanté par tous at
il entraîné par jean tu es là chez un
ami on doit mener une vie en dehors tout
ça quand tu as choisi la musique afin
que j'ai vraiment l'instrument comptait
quand l hôte et les arts dont la non
mais quand nadal à l'audition de la
nouvelle star tu t'es dit moi je veux je
veux gagner je veux y aller mais
craignent de faire mon métier ou pas du
tout mais pas par hasard j'ai perdu ma
voix moi au bout du premier prêt
mentalement j'étais choqué de d'être la
bête de passer une étape j'étais à fond
ben justement gardons at-on casting
regarde au casting c'est juste le temps
de calais on en a pour une petite on l'a
passé
[Applaudissements]
là
une petite précision parce que je suis
sait il ya une jurisprudence magalie vaé
en fait comme c'est un échec industriel
elle fait moins de 100000 vente à partir
de magali vais y avait plus de 1 0 on ne
donnait plus une avance de 1 million
d'euros sur recettes comme c'était le
cas pour tous les autres mais de 500
milles seulement je crois que la
nouvelle star c'était 100 1000 euros là
ne l'avons pas du tout à jouer mais on
dirait un contrat aidé 0 vous c'était un
million sur un point gagnant à partir de
magali c'était 500 milles pour les trois
saisons suivantes
on a le casting dame elle regarde au
bout et ça voulait dire on est heureux
la bohème la bohème
nous ne manquions un jour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors j'ai décroché des illusions rêve
vous dites quoi géraldine sting surtout
que la mel b a tout dit en fait est fait
car pour gagner un télé crochet c'est
pas une assurance vie pour faire
carrière et perd il faut travailler il
faut bosser il faut se remettre en
question il faut bien s'entourer
il faut rebondir il faut disparaître on
reçoit aussi plein d'artistes parfois
qui n' ont pas fait télé crochet et qui
disparaît du jour au lendemain bien sûr
après la paresse ou pas du tout
d'ailleurs
donc si je peux me permettre la star
c'est la chanson c'est les chansons qui
crée un lien avec les gens c'est pas ta
voix tu veux michael jackson il a eu des
moments où c'était compliqué oui mais
dit 'tiens michael jackson ya des
moments où c'était ça mais est ce que tu
peux espérer toi on est perdue à un
moment
alors il ose dire c'est moi par exemple
je vous le dis j'ai eu cet après midi
j'ai juste après midi rené la taupe il
au fond du trou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi je la trouvais très moyenne cette
blague lé bonheur d'avoir un début
d'infection à l'effet nocebo par les
télé-crochets rien ne sert à gagner il
faut se faire éliminer à pois on se rend
compte que des personnes qu'elle fait
pas mal fait et les numéros de vente
davantage ne sont pas les premiers
bénéficiaires est d'ailleurs ceux qui
votent pour les gens dans les télé
crochets ne sont pas forcément ceux qui
achètent des délais mais surtout il ya
les contre exemples alors ça aussi ça
veut rien dire avait désolé parce qu'il
ya nolwenn ya jenifer revient sur le
métier moi je pense qu'il n'y a pas de
lois comme diamant où les actrices alors
il ya des années on apprécie luan elle
est candidate lors de la deuxième saison
de the voice
elle finit éliminé en demi finale c'est
une des cinq plus grandes stars qu'on a
à offrir c'est que avant le signalement
battle est avant le film loi ne vend
rien j'ai remporté mes singles qu'elle
sort elle devra musulmans rien et le
film ce marché derrière du coup ils
ressortent et single qui deviennent des
cartes on a eu des bus info
[Musique]
depuis
oh
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
o'keefe la chanter ou qu'il a chanté
j'adore il avait alors qualifié le
verdict il faut dire aussi que les gens
en ont eu marre des arnaques faux pas de
langue de bois ici parce que ce qui
s'est passé dans certains télé crochet
c'est que des gens étaient éliminés très
tôt parce qu'ils avaient déjà des
contrats que c'était préparé on s'est
dit on peut les faire sortir maintenant
il commence à bosser pour nous c'est
parce que derrière chaque télé crochet y
ait une maison de disques est prêt à ap
l'artiste essaie les gens en ont eu
marre mais dans l'ensemble c'est d'être
révélée même eu une perte du congrès à
ce que je vous demande c'est les télé
crochets ça quand même fait moi ce que
je vois et je pense que c'est ce que
voit que les téléspectateurs aujourd'hui
si vous prenez maintenant les 30 plus
grandes stars de la chanson un tiers
vient quand même et télé crochet nadine
nolwenn leroy milan ac on a un extrait
d'un wayne leroy elles vont énormément
de disques kamel et à jennifer jae-hwan
jaeckel j'ai signalé foncière non mais
c'est vrai je suis bien aurait bien doré
a surtout bien doré vient quand même de
télé crochet donc ça quand même c'est
quand même rêver ça reste quand même
réduit des grosses stars regarder
nolwenn notamment
[Musique]
on me dit je t'ai vu si je tiens mon
coeur
[Musique]
c'est vrai
c'est vraiment un réservoir de talents
exceptionnels
et voilà après c'est vrai que comme a
dit amel moi je pense aussi que c'est
une question c'est dur pour tondre comme
un animateur voile amateur il évidemment
et bien sûr regarder et à plus long
reste à venir j'ai envie de dire quand
on me demande des conseils c'est la
croche sol
je reste à vous alors ils ont visité
aznavour avoue redouter a toujours dit
dans les télé crochets il ya 15% qui
réussissent exactement comme dans la
vraie vie sans le télé crochet même si
je trouve le foot est dit dans cette
phrase
honnêtement il avait été vu de tout le
monde et on aime aussi les chanteurs
issus et télé crochet parce qu'on a
l'impression qu'on les a vus naître
on les a suivis et donc du coup on a une
relation affective différente on nous
annonce qu'on les connaît et on les voit
bloqué par donc reborn chef pas beau
mais c'est vrai que ça crée une espèce
de relation avec les gens et moi j'ai su
que je croise des gens dans la rue mais
ils sont énervés
oui mais que deux que j'ai perdu mais je
dis mais ça fait 15 ans madani cinq
albums mais quand même je comprends pas
assez de l'arnaqué mais ça s'est mis
alors les gens ici ici volaille semaine
le carrossier télé crochet c'est julien
doré regardez qui je partage la fiche
sur
[Musique]
mais là
je sais pour jour
[Musique]
que je sais
thomas
dumas
je suis fait d'écarter moi vraiment son
dernier album et un carton il remplit
east asian marteau mais c'est vrai que
c'était des personnalités incroyable je
trouve personnellement qu'on a moins de
personnalité comme ça il ya eu qu un
jean slim and dernièrement comme on en a
eu quand il ya eu un mail quand et où
jennifer quand il ya eu à l'époque
surtout on savait dès le premier prime
qui est légal mais je viendrai oui il
aime aussi un bourgeois et ce qui est
étonnant c'est rien c'est que le prat le
télé-crochet de plus cher de l'histoire
c'est donc je vole c'est quasiment 20
millions d'euros sur la première chaîne
d'europe et c'est lui qui a sorti le
moins de 2,2 de barrières au delà des
gars l'accord actuel n'est pas vraiment
sorti alors et non voilà elle est
surprenant c zéro alors vous vous avez
fait notamment une vidéo
voilà j'ai vu une vidéo sur un stack est
exceptionnel vous avez fait une reprise
de diageo oui je kiffe cette chanson
regardez
g
[Musique]
il a qu'à beaucoup par hadopi au regard
d'un amour et bilal qui cartonne il a
une gêne à plus de deux millions
d'années des accès 7e lui a répondu ce
coup là janet jackson lui a répondu tout
à fait bédard instagram